Bố tổng thăm bự của quay nha ngày 1 chiến thân sáng cho biết, ngà đã trình khai một đường không kích quay mô lớn,
nhằm vân yêu khu vực trí lãnh thổ của quay nha, bối tổng cộng bốn trăm trí mới trình bố kì tần công,
gôn tên lừa và mấy bây con người lại ua vê.
Theo phía ua quay nha, gần lượng không có nước này đã đánh trạng toàn bộ bốn tên lửa xíu vật em khi nhanh,
mới tên lửa hành trình cà án một công một, hai tên lửa trong rời đàn các hát bạm một pê,
và một tên lửa hành trình cà án bà lâm, ngoài ra, ở quay nha cho biết, bắn dơi hai chăm bởi vì bảy ua vê các ngoài,
cho khi hai tên lửa cà hay hai và một chăm tảy bảo ua vê khác,
bị chế ăn định từ và mất phương vấn.
Tuy nhiên, ua quay nha cũng sáng nhận một số mạnh vỡ tên lửa và ua vê đã gây chảy vận hại,
cả ít nhất người để điểm bao gồm thiê, đi nhi pro,
Sepurisia, Bali Ví.
Lực lượng cộng hộ đu trình khai nhánh chẳng để kiểm tra thi thải vào hỗ trưởng như sân.
Chúng khi đó, một số mọi người phân tý độc lập như Amg Ka Maping,
thào giỏi dễ biến chiến sự qua sự hiệm mọi trưa rằng,
các một tiêu quân sự cuộc thề như sân bay đúng nâu,
khó nguyên liệu ra đa và sự chế huy tại ua quay nha,
cũng đã bị tấn công bằng tên lửa kinh sân và tá thái hại.
Đáng chú ý, rất quan rất khu tế bày tỏ hoa nghe,
bây tên bầu đánh trạng một chăm phần trăm tên lửa kinh sân,
loại bố khí có tất độ và phản năng cơ động rất cao.
Một số chuyên gia đình giá, đây có thể là tuyên bố mắt tình tinh thần,
cho bối kỳng dào chàng lâu thân.